[MUSIC]
Hello, and welcome to today's panel,
MBA Student Insights,
Consumer Focused Careers at Stanford GSB.
My name is Rebecca and I'm
a second year MBA student here at the GSB.
Am joined by Christina and
Fiza,
two of my classmate and
MBA, too, students as well.
They are each pursuing career interest
in the consumer focused business space.
And in our time together, we'll be
talking about the student experience
here at the GSB and how we are using to
prepare for careers that after school.
Please be aware that we won't be
talking about the admissions process,
the application, or financial aid today.
You can consult the website or
contact the MBA admissions office for
that information.
Now let's begin with introductions.
As I mentioned before,
I'm currently an MBA, too.
Prior to the GSB, I lived in Houston,
Texas where I worked as a technology
consultant before transitioning
into strategic communications and
strategy for an oil and gas company.
I came to the GSB to pursue a career shift
into marketing at a consumer focused
company, and I've used my experiences
here to explore that space.
Now turning to Cristina, I'd love for
you to introduce yourself.
>> Thank you.
So my name is Cristina La Marca,
I'm from Italy.
And prior to coming to the GSB I was a
management consultant based in London and
later in Australia.
And then I worked for an oil and
gas company, as well, for
a year before coming here.
And I came because myself, too,
I wanted to move and
transition into the consumer retail space.
But at the time I didn't know
really where, that's me.
>> Yeah, thank you.
Now I'd like to have Faeza
introduce herself as well.
>> Of course, My name is Faeza,
I'm from Panama originally.
I worked three years at Proctor and
Gamble doing brand management across
Latin America for
brands such as Pampers and Charmin.
Had a great time.
But I realized that as I
was moving up in my career,
there were some skills that
I still needed to develop.
So I came in the GSB to try
to round up those skills.
>> Wonderful, thank you so much,
we're so glad to have both
of you here with us today.
So I'd like to go ahead and dive in.
We've heard from the traditional
route into this space,
as well as a more untraditional route.
So I'd like to just hear a little bit
about what your decision criteria was when
you decided to apply to the GSB.
>> So, for me,
I guess there were other schools in other
cities that maybe looked more appealing
from a consumer point of view,
such as, for example, London or New York.
But, what really drove me to
Stanford was the possibility
to actually experience
the Silicon Valley culture and
see what applications it might have
into the consumer and retail space.
Also, there was I think plenty
of alumni from Stanford
that either started consumer
retail companies and
cover prominent positions
in larger corporations,
the club seemed to me to have
a very strong reputation and
I was comfortable coming here.
>> Yeah.
>> In my case, when I was looking
what schools to apply to,
the the GSB definitely stood out because
two of the things that I was looking for
were developing my soft skills.
So, managing others,
how to have difficult conversations,
how to project power and
project confidence.
And the GSB definitely have the best
professors for those courses.
So I knew that I wanted
to apply to the GSB.
I also really liked the opportunities
to explore topics outside of the GSB.
Stanford let's you take classes as
a graduate student in any of the schools.
And that's a great tool to have as
a leader when you don't know exactly what
industry you might want to
go to after the GSB.
>> I've had a very similar experience.
I came to the GSB because of
a mix of both the culture and
the relativity to the Silicon Valley.
So coming from a tech background, I
thought that was a really good segue into
understanding how that really
related to the consumer space.
And there's just so many different
experiences as you guys know, being able
to go visit companies or having some
of those entrepreneurs come to campus.
And then the exposure to developing
both the soft and hard skills, I think,
it's pretty unparalleled and
other experiences.
So, really, really glad I
made the choice to come here.
So, starting to dive into some of
the academics, you've talked about, Faeza,
some of the soft skills that you've
developed, maybe you can share some of
what your favorite classes have been
to help you develop some of those.
>> I have two favorite
classes that I've taken, and
they're in the opposite spectrum
of hard and soft skill.
The first one,
it's going to be a GSB classic,
it's touchy interpersonal dynamics.
I think it really helped me open my
eyes in terms of how do I come across to
other people and where am I not
being an efficient communicator.
So I think those are learnings
that I'm going to keep forever.
And on the other spectrum, the other
extreme, I really enjoyed optimization and
simulation [LAUGH], or
SM as it's famously called.
As I was taking that class,
my initial thought was,
if I knew this a year ago I would
have saved so many hours of my life.
Just in terms of optimizing making
budgets or calculating a rise or
just being more efficient overall.
So those are the two classes that I would
recommend everyone going into CPG or
going into a consumer focused
class to definitely take.
>> And I imagine,
did the name scare you off at first?
Did you imagine you were going to get so
much value from it?
[LAUGH]
>> I know, so OSM is a required class.
As in, you have to take it as part of your
foundations curriculum your first year.
If I had to choose it on my own,
I don't know if I would have,
just because it sounds intimidating.
But the fact that Stanford thinks
ahead and knows what kind of courses
are going to be useful in your life,
was just such a huge help.
>> Thank you, and Christina,
any courses that stand out for
you that have directly related
to a career in this space?
>> Yes, so for me, I guess the first one
was product launch that we took last year,
and it's an advanced marketing class with,
yes, with.
I wasn't familiar with the space, and so
it really helped me understand how
customers interact with the product.
Another class that was really helpful was
an across the street class at the design
school.
And there we basically
focused on need finding.
So it's part of the design
thinking process there for
which Stanford is extremely famous for.
And there I really developed my skills
in finding problems that matter
to customers and developing products
that actually address those problems.
So those were my two highlights.
>> Great, I think that for me, a couple
that really stood out to me actually,
apart from interpersonal dynamics,
which you mentioned,
and product launch, were I took a class
on consumer search and marketing.
So learning how to leverage
tools such as Google AdWords and
Facebook advertising to actually
understand how you place an ad.
So if you're looking at A website or
looking at Facebook and
you have an ad that pops up that's
relatively familiar to something that
you might have just been looking at.
We learned actually how that happens.
And for me that was an extremely valuable
learning that I was actually able to take
forward into my summer experiences and
summer internships.
So that was a really valuable course for
me.
And then I am also currently in
a course called Startup Garage.
And I know that Christina has
had experience not as well, but
you actually get to test out
building your own product and
learning how to acquire customers and how
how do you get close to your consumers?
How do you interview them and
how do you really touch base to understand
what a core need of that market is?
And so for me, I've learned a lot of
really essential marketing and consumer
facing tactics that have been really
valuable for me in my career.
If I choose to go
the entrepreneurship route or
if I choose to go the big business route,
you're always going to have customers.
So those have been two really
valuable experiences for me.
So apart from the academics, as I know and
I'm sure you guys can all relate to, the
DSB offers so many different experiences.
And as much as we are in classes,
we're also taking part on
a number of different activities.
So maybe you can talk
about some of the clubs or
other extracurricular
experiences you've had.
>> Sure, so of course there is
the Retail and Consumer Club.
And, for example, just yesterday
Stich Fix came and told us about
physically their story from the very
origin in 2012 until the IPO.
It was extremely interesting.
It's senior management that comes and
you can ask very open questions and
they're happy to respond.
And then another experience
from last year was
being a part in the marketing
team of the winter gala.
It's a charity gala
that the GSB organizes,
that the students at the GSB organize.
And that was a good way for
me to come together with classmates
that I would have not otherwise met.
And it was my first marketing experience.
So that was also very interesting.
>> I'll go ahead.
Because I've had more of
a traditional background,
when I came to the GSB, I was looking to
expand those skills into consumer spaces
that I might not have access to before.
So I'm very involved with the Art and
Entertainment Club and the Education Club.
The Arts and Entertainment Club
because it's such a different industry
that I'm very curious to see how consumers
operate in such an industry that I'm not
necessarily going to go into, but it's
good to flex those muscles in terms of
understanding different
types of consumers.
The Education Club I'm very involved with,
because I'm a dual-degree major with
the School of Education, for two reasons.
One, I think with the changes in
technology that are occurring at such
a fast pace, a big part of marketing
is now going to be educating consumers.
So I think you can learn a lot
from learning how to teach,
learning how people learn basically
[LAUGH] and how to use that in marketing.
[COUGH] So you not only have the
opportunity to look into consumer focus.
Groups or companies, you're able also to
use those same skills and flex them out in
other industries, or other areas that you
might not have exposure to after the GSB.
>> And that's such an important
skill set to have.
I noticed that even though I was in big
tech and big oil and gas companies,
what I learned is that oftentimes you have
a company that's setting the strategy,
and it could be a marketing strategy.
But there's not enough resources deployed
to actually teach the consumers,
or teach even the rest of the business
about how to get from point A to point B.
So the education aspect is so important.
And I think that's such a unique
way to look at a dual degree.
And then look at how you
actually build your skills.
Having come in with the marketing
experience that you did.
>> Exactly, how do you teach
someone to use autonomous cars?
[LAUGH] Or how do you like something that
you can't even picture having in part of
your everyday life.
How do you go about starting something so
drastically different?
>> Right, and
I imagine that before coming here,
you probably weren't even thinking about,
how would I try and
convince someone about how
to use an autonomous car.
>> [LAUGH]
>> What is an autonomous?
They're already out there, [LAUGH] yes.
>> So it's another thing that we get
being here at the Silicon Valley.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> That's wonderful.
Well, apart from clubs, I'd just be
curious about career opportunities.
So we talked about some of the clubs,
such as the Retail and Consumer Club.
I know that there's a lot of different
treks that those clubs take part in
to make sure that you're able to go,
see these companies,
see what roles are out there.
So can you maybe talk a little
bit more about the BBLs or
some tracks that you've been on.
And how that's opened doors up into
the career management center or
into career opportunities?
>> So BBLs and-
>> So what is a BBL?
>> Yes, so
it's the [CROSSTALK] [LAUGH] It's
basically an hour during
lunch time where the GSB
intentionally doesn't
schedule any classes,
so that companies or
guest speakers or alumni can come and
basically, they either host the panel or
just give a talk about
a specific topic of a company.
The Retail and Consumer Club I think
host at least two or three a month.
And so we have a lot of consumer
focus companies coming.
And those have been extremely
helpful because you get to meet,
beyond what you hear from the company,
you actually get to meet generally
the CEO or head of strategy, or the COO.
And it's a good way to
make an introduction,
offer your thoughts about the specific
topic, and create our relationship.
And I know many of my classmates
including myself have managed to
actually either serves potential
internship opportunities or
past GSB full-time offer through there.
>> Yeah, and I know for me I went to
a brown bag lunch hosted by DFS Group,
which is a company that manages a number
of the duty free stores that you
see in international airports,
especially across Asia.
And we had had the VPN North America
come to visit and
come to discuss their business model.
And it wasn't a company that I had been
considering previous to them coming to
campus, but ended up talking,
having a conversation offline
with the VPN North America.
And then ended up being able to
do an international internship,
which is called a GEMx,
which is a global immersion program that's
offered by the Career Management Center.
And was able to go over there for
a month, and
work in their international branding team.
So, like Christina was saying, there's so
many different opportunities that you're
able to leverage from
the brown bag lunches.
And a couple of ones that have stood out
to me have been, both the Retail and
Consumer Club that has already been
mentioned a number of times, but
also the Marketing Club.
We're actually working on planning a trek
to go visit some of these companies.
And how we choose the companies is often
by looking at companies that are doing
really interesting things right now,
in this space, but also companies
that are looking to hire interns or
hire individuals for a full-time career.
So we can start to prepare and
set people up to move into these spaces.
So I'd be curious, Faiza,
what really stands out to you
when thinking about this?
>> I also really enjoyed all the speakers
I would get to have on campus,
not only because it's opportunities
to interact with CEOs, but
it's also opportunities to get into their
brains and understand The consumer trends
and the challenges that they see in
the areas in the next couple of years.
So I remember Lolli & Pops
coming to campus and,
it having just an insight
into what starting your own
company in a very consumer focused-
>> And it's candy.
>> So everyone likes candy.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, but
it's very interesting to be able to very
quickly, in an hour, get such a deep
perspective of the consumer trends in such
a wider range from retail to food and
beverage to CPG to, blanking out.
>> Exactly.
And I know we talked a little before,
earlier in the week,
about the career managements that
are offering a number of workshops and
sessions to help facilitate
the job search process.
So maybe you can talk a little bit
about something that stood out to you.
>> Yeah, so,
the one that was definitely useful for
me immediately was
the two hour job search.
[LAUGH] By Steve.
I think it's Steve Dalton.
You don't have to be a consumer
focused person who'd benefit
from workshops like that.
But all the workshops that I've found very
useful are very intentional in terms of
the skill that they want you to learn or
what you're going to want to get out of.
So I also really enjoyed How to
Make Memorable Presentations.
Or How to Network as
an International Student.
Or it was, I think it's called
How to Manage, US Networks.
So I think there have
all been very detailed,
Very detailed, business skills
that I'm going to get in one hour.
You go and you actually do end up
getting that skill by the end.
>> And then you're able to
apply it to the job search?
>> Yea, exactly.
>> Afterwards.
Are there any trips that really stand out,
you mention that you
haven't gone on any center.
But are there any trips that just
maybe a required global studies trip.
>> Yeah.
>> Or other experiences that you might
have had that have lended way to learning
more about the consumer space in multiple
different countries across the world
besides just our little bubble-
>> Yeah.
>> In the Silicon Valley.
[LAUGH]
>> So many, I recently led GST to Mexico.
And one of the meetings that we had was
with Mexico CEO for Kimberly Clark.
And we had a panel with him and
a politician to talk about how
changes in regulation are going to affect
the company in the upcoming years.
So changes in NAFTA or
the new presidential elections that
are going to be happening in Mexico.
And it's such an interesting conversation
to be able to have with a CEO and
a politician from a country
that you're not familiar with.
>> Wow, and
how did you get that meeting or
get to lead this trip in the first place?'
>> Yeah, so he's an alum.
So we were able to connect with him.
I might have already slipped in that I
was interested [LAUGH] in Kimberly Clark.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I really admire the company so
as a leader to go to choose what companies
you want to incorporate on your trips.
It's a great opportunity
network with people that
you might not necessarily know
how to introduce yourself.
And having to take 25 MBAs that
are interested in your company.
Is a great excuse to get to meet
anyone they want in an new country.
>> That's amazing.
>> Yeah.
>> What is been your experience with
alumni outreach?
>> Super friendly, I've never not gotten
a response from an alum basically.
>> It's a pretty tight community,
I think that's one of the benefits
of having such a small class.
>> Yes.
>> But it's, I've had the same experience.
I know that-
>> Yeah.
>> For me I a number of the trips that
I've planned are trips are that I've gone
on as you reach out to an alumni, and
if you don't respond in a couple of days,
they send an apology note that-
>> Yep.
>> They're sorry that it's taken so long-
>> But
everyone's-
>> Yeah.
>> Been very, very receptive.
And I know that in the career
management center,
one of the advisors there, every time
I go will send me a list of alumnus
that says hey reach out to this person and
just grab a coffee.
Or go to their office and
see what their doing.
Ask how they decided their own
career path-
>> Yeah.
>> And
especially transitioning into this space.
That's been beyond valuable for me.
>> Yeah, I was doing a in Tanzania and
had a lot of free time.
And surprisingly, my nights corresponded
to very early morning in the south or
in the US, and I was able to have so
many Skype conversations with alumni in
my free time that I was super surprised.
Just blindly reaching out to people it's a
foreign as I was trying to understand what
I wanted to do after I graduated and
leveraging my summer free time in
a way to just hear about as many
people's experiences as I could-
>> That's really valuable.
>> And was able to do that.
All the way across the world.
[LAUGH]
>> Christina I'd be curious about any
trips that stand out or
alumni connections that have really
helped you boost your career.
Especially transitioning from oil and
gas as well and consulting.
>> Yeah, so this summer I was
returning to San Francisco, I was
doing also a globally merchant experience
in Thailand, and an e-commerce start-up.
And I stopped in London, and I just wanted
to see what the opportunities were there.
And so I reached out to just a couple of
alumni that I knew were in London and
one of them wasn't even apart
of the consumer retail space.
And within I think, I don't know,
maybe 12 hours I was put in touch
with 5 people who were working in
companies that I could be interested in.
And I managed to meet them within
48 hours in London, all of them.
So, even abroad internationally, I found
that the network is definitely there,
and the people are excited
to help you out, and
that was really a pleasant surprise for
me.
>> And that's really important,
that it's not just this bubble
where people are helpful.
But, I'd be curious,
are you thinking about potentially
staying here after school?
Or why is that international
connection valuable for you?
>> I guess for me as an international,
I definitely want to spend one year
at least in the US after school.
But I want to keep myself the option of
going back to London where I used to work.
And I think in Europe there's a lot
of happening in the consumer and
retail space.
It's a smaller market, more pragmatic but
there's a lot of brands there
that are interesting to me.
And so just nurturing those relationships
and staying in touch over the year.
Those people are still there, and it's
not a transactional exchange of emails.
It's he's very much like, hey I thought
these could be of interest of you.
Like these are my thoughts and
they replied.
It's great.
>> And that's the smartest thing to do.
I think that probably one of
the most valuable things that
we've all experienced here.
It's just being able to ask questions.
So part of the learning process,
outside the classroom is just being
immersed in, in a national perspective and
being immersed in learning
about Kimberly Clark in Mexico.
Or planning trips or BVLs, and there's so
many different opportunities to immerse
ourselves and
being able to learn more about the space.
So what I would like to do
is shift a little bit into
thinking about career goals after school.
So we're all interested in space.
The two of you have had experience over
the summer learning more about the space
through internship,
can you talk a little bit about
where you are going after school?
>> Sure.
So one option for me is to go back
into consulting but this time in
the consumer and retail space, and
I know that the option is there.
One other option,
which is what I'm pursuing right
now is actually starting my own brand.
It's like a fashion brand and
it's what has been incredible to me is
the amount of support that I've actually
got here from an academic point of view
in terms of classes that I'm taking
that are supporting my objective.
The professors, and
the knowledge that they bring, and
the mentoring that they do.
And then once again, the alumni network,
and the willingness that they have in
sharing their own learnings, especially
in the more entrepreneurship space.
So those are my two options.
It's like an evolving thinking process.
There's time before graduation.
But I can see how now, options
are starting to sort of pop up in front
of you, and you almost have too many
options to choose, I would say.
And so I think that was
also extremely valuable for
me to see that despite the fact
that we are in this tech.
[LAUGH] It's a tech-focused area, still,
there are so many opportunities for
people who are interested in
the CPG consumer retail space.
>> And I think that's one of the things to
highlight is that obviously we've all done
the hard work to make sure
that those options are there.
But even properly, the person that
certainly set amount of work has found
that there's multiple options and
multiple career path in this space,
which has been a huge opportunity for
myself.
>> And they're all so tempting.
>> Yes [LAUGH].
>> It's so hard to be choiceful in what
you want to do after the GSB, because
you just get tempted by so many cool
things that you can do after you graduate.
So I found the CMC super helpful in trying
to determine what is exactly that I
want out of my next job, and
how do I stay true to that?
So I've had a lot of one-on-one advising
conversations with advisors at the CMC,
to really write down in hard stone,
what is it exactly that I'm looking for,
and what do I want out of my next job.
>> And you know what you want.
>> Yes.
>> So maybe you can share a little
bit with us about what you're
planning to do next year.
>> So after at least five months.
>> [LAUGH] not even next year.
>> I know.
I'm going to be doing a Retail
Leadership Rotational Program at Amazon.
I'll be able to test out different
career paths within a very
consumer-focused industry, so I'll be
rotating between marketing operations,
third-party vendors, in different areas.
I like the ability to be able
to use a lot of the skills that
I've learned at the GSB, so
operations are not my strength.
But being able to know how to do it is so
important, just because as you move up,
if you become a category leader, you'll
have operations people reporting to you.
So knowing what they
do is super important.
So I really value having that broad
landscape of skills and experiences,
which this rotational program
is going to do for me.
>> I think that's fantastic, and I know
you'll be able to use the experience, and
basically, the proximity to where we
are now to build into that e-commerce
platform, so I think that's fantastic.
And Christina, you understated a bit
of what you've been doing as well.
So Christina, I'm going to take
this opportunity to brag about her,
has been working around the clock, and
has really just harnessed so much interest
from our classmates, and what she's been
working on in the entrepreneurial space.
And although it's entrepreneurial, it's
also very driven by her consumer interest,
and I think the opportunities
that you've had and
the exposure to everything in this
area has been beyond valuable.
And to say that it's the community,
I think, is the wrong way to angle it.
I think that you've just done
a tremendous job driving that forward and
figuring out exactly where
your passions are, and
[INAUDIBLE] these past years
have really created for you.
>> Yeah, and business school is such
a risk-free environment to do so.
There's so
many of us that are testing products,
services, not just in the consumer
retail space, everywhere.
And we work altogether at the co-lab,
which is a shared working space.
Their ideas, they're throwing from corner
to the other of the room all the time,
and it's risk-free.
You know that you can always go out,
look out there, and
find plenty of opportunities, but for
some of us, it will be a full-time career.
Entrepreneurship will turn
into something full-time.
>> Definitely.
>> As someone that's not doing
an entrepreneurial role,
being able to test out all the products.
>> Yes [LAUGH].
>> It's amazing [LAUGH].
>> That is true, that is true.
And I know for myself, I don't plan
to go the entrepreneurial route.
But I'm still trying to figure
out which space is right for me.
Definitely in the consumer space.
I think you just have such a competitive
advantage when you can touch and
feel the products and
know exactly who you're marketing for.
So ideally, I want to be a user of
the product that I eventually end up
marketing, or the company I end up working
for, so still trying to figure that out.
But with that said, I'd love to just
ask you guys one final question.
If there's anything, any type of advice
that you would like to recommend to
other students that might
potentially join the GSB community,
any just lasting words or
pieces of advice for them?
>> I think that once you get into the GSB,
you have so many opportunities,
it's very overwhelming.
It's hard to choose what
courses you want to take,
what extracurriculars you
want to be involved with.
My biggest advice is dream big.
Whenever you're trying to make choices in
terms of what skills do I want to build,
what classes do I want to take,
think about the wildest role
that you think you might have.
Like, I'm going to be CEO of X, and
what do I need to get there, and
then leverage the GSB to do as much
as you can to prepare yourself for
that huge big role that
you're going to have one day.
>> I think that's so true.
For me, it's be open-minded.
If I had even guessed the number of things
that I'd be involved in two years ago,
I think I would have been so far-off.
I mean, I had the opportunity to write
a case on the mental health space,
and I would have never said that
I would do that two years ago.
And then I've been able intern in
a couple of really incredible companies,
over this summer,
focused on the consumer space.
And the access that we get to a number
of leaders is just unbelievable,
so I'd just say be open-minded.
Don't limit yourself.
Don't come in with hard and
fast rules about what you have to do,
and won't do, for that matter.
But be open-minded, set a plan for
what you really want to accomplish, and
just go after it.
So I think that I've learned the most from
those unexpected experiences, and I think
that's the best advice that I can give to
anyone that's thinking about coming here.
So with that, I'd like to thank both
of you for being here today, and
we wish you all a wonderful
rest of your day.
Thank you.
[MUSIC]